Welcome everybody to the next reader genes podcast. We're going to go over questions that were submitted on the reader genes course.
So let's get started with the questions.
Just a few today. Is it possible that my nine siblings could have some of the same gene defects that I have?
Well, it's not only possible, but it's definite. So understand that you receive one allele from your mother and one allele from your father.
So if let's say you're both your mother and your father have a double allele defect on, let's say the one of the pond one genes that you will definitely have a double allele defect on that specific pond one gene and every single sibling.
And your family would have every offspring of your mother and father if they both have a double allele defect on a specific gene, every offspring will also have a double allele defect.
If your father has a double allele defect and your mother has a single allele defect, you have a 25% chance of just having a single allele defect.
And it's the same thing with your siblings or your children. So you have a double allele defect on a gene and your husband does that child's father does, then there's 100% chance that they will also have a double allele defect. If you have a single allele defect at here and the child's father has no defects on that gene, the child cannot have a double allele defect.
So it can't be a two, it can only be a one of these that child only has a 25% chance of having a single allele defect on one of that gene and a 75% chance of not having a defect.
So that's all that works.
So do understand though that there can't be differences to what I just said because you could have acquired defects. So those are inherited defects and acquired defect is different meeting that
You might not have had any defects on us, but particularly let's use pond one gene when you were bored, but because you were exposed to some heavy poisons or something at some point in your life, it damaged those genes and now you have a defect on those genes.
That's the argument with this mRNA therapy that's being posed as a vaccine is that it can be damaging people's genes.
I would love to see studies never publish them if they do them.
I would love to have some patients that did their own studies and see what genes are affected pre and post vaccine.
I would never get anybody to do that either, but it would be different things can damage our genes. And then if you had, let's say you had no defects on a gene and you had your children, and then later we're exposed to some talks and damage she's damaged damaging your genes, then of course you're not passing them up to the children because you already had children.
If the caffeine gene is not highlighted, does that mean it's okay to drink coffee? Yeah, so if I didn't highlight that and make a note of it that it's okay to drink coffee, obviously there's other issues other than just genetics with coffee you could have, you know, a food sensitivity to coffee.
So, but that the caffeine gene has to do with the caffeine, not just coffee, it's caffeine, and it's the genetic issue with caffeine, not a peptide antibody issue is in the sensitivity.
The oxalate pathway has I has not been highlighted, even though my kidney stones are oxalate based. Yeah, because you can have no genetic defects, but you can still have issues because of other reasons too.
You could end up with kidney stones because you dehydrate number one reason why you get kidney stone is you've been dehydrated for a long period of time, and you will still build up oxalates you if you have a diet that's high in oxalates.
And even though you process them very well through your gut and you don't have a predisposition for a long genetic standpoint to have kidney stones, you could still get kidney stones.
Just same thing with your detoxification pathway, jeans, you could have just clean set of gold people of 50 and clean on one jeans, and that you have major detox issues because you're exposed to a lot of toxins here, you've damaged your liver in other ways, you've, you know,
you did a lot of alcohol, you've used different medications that damaged your liver, so there's a greater picture than just genetics, that's why you do it to look at the big picture of everything.
All right, that's the questions we have submitted, so thank you for participating.
Well, this is a blessing for everybody.